can you ever [ __ ] with adderall i feel
like you and i like drugs i've tried i
don't know
sure yeah you like it you like it i
don't yeah you like it
you're the kind of guy you're the kind
of guy who will go um let's see
yeah do a couple tick tacks correct and
let's do some adding wrong because it's
here
seven cups of coffee nicotine nicotine
and i'm gonna have all the coffee and
then i'm ready to go give me an entire
cup and a big
and then i'm gonna bench 415 pounds and
then and then you might even go
i have to bench and i'm just saying you
might you might go
uh what is this syringe
uh-huh you might do that you might do
that and then you might
is that anaphor you know what if i was
my skin's not tight enough
if if i was on sauce or anything i'd be
way bigger
yep he's a good size i mean yeah you
don't look like you're i mean you see me
doing cardio yeah
yeah look what yeah right what you don't
want to get bigger right you've said
over and over you hate being your size
yeah yeah look at me trying to get
smaller
i'm just asking i wanted to ask one
question i'm getting attacked
all right i did trt like three years ago
i've talked about this on rogan and my
face
you never told me that i blew up you
never told me that you keep a lot of
things maybe two maybe two years no he
you know no you you did tell him that
yeah i told you that i tried it yeah it
keeps me in the dark my face
blew i got moon face now you get some my
face blew the [ __ ] right now i was
sweating right now you're walking
natural
yeah you're not running any gear no we
think i'm on
anavar i don't know why you're smiling
answer me a question without smiling
okay
let me ask you a question bring your
hands down get vulnerable i am no
no you guys are you're bracing yourself
look me in the eye
you can't even do it you're getting into
it have i dabbled in someone's
dog can daddy not try some stuff
i got a boy who works for you he goes he
goes hey man between us
if i were to send you a test would you
pass it i and i just responded like
don't send the test
i whatever you're doing i think it looks
good to be completely honest with you so
i'm i'm i appreciate that he just does
bcaas
protein i'm sure he does that's all it
is if i ask him the questions
he could never am i sweating
my goals 20 pounds by the end of
september i know by the time i do the
denver show i'm gonna lose 20 pounds
you're always safe with me so whatever
you're doing i don't care
you can always talk to me so do you
believe i'm not on it yeah you're
definitely not
done did you see him bench 315 that's a
lot of weight
did you i have my suspicions as well you
bet you better oh
where am i going to get it what about
how much oh oh oh
oh i don't know our friend mark harlow
you think i would take some [ __ ] you're
close friends what nyquil freaks me out
no i know and you don't like caffeine
yeah no no you're you're not you're
you're
naughty all natty bcaa is protein shakes
i don't think you take that no i don't
terrified i'm terrified of everything
you do do you do bcaas
you do you do a little um
it's in protein drinks so you do protein
yeah you're going deep with this
building right now yeah bro he goes in
the gym he started doing the stuff
you've wanted to for a long time you've
wanted to just kind of push it a little
bit yeah
well i think now i've just accepted that
you know you've told me this forever
just accept my size
yeah just be funny that's what i'm doing
i'm a huge fan
and i used to be super self-conscious of
posting like workout videos
on my instagram because i'm like uh
stand up guys really don't do
working out and it's like oh they can
suck my dick right i've never
i've never had understood why he would
be i was sure he'd be at [ __ ] parties
and he would stand with his legs like
far apart so he was
the size of everybody and then we're at
this training party and he goes like
this he looks at me goes hey
i'm enormous i was like yeah but
you know that's that body dysmorphia
right yeah yeah but be
bigger and stronger than everybody with
your ears it's awesome no i feel you on
that you just feel like
dudes liking girls yeah yeah what's the
problem i mean i have no problem i've
never understood it
yeah i've never understood it just be
big as [ __ ] i even asked gianni i was
like okay i get this video of me dad
left in 600 should we post it he's like
what what what the [ __ ] yes
best i'm like i'm worried it's not going
to work in 415 like it's
like nothing i'm the strongest guy in
comedy name somebody stronger
well you are the strongest guy you can
also beat up everybody